east lincolnshire like the rest of the
country has seen growing numbers of
families
struggling financially
in lockdown we saw how school welfare
officers from skegness academy
were ensuring disadvantaged children
didn't lose their education
i've got a laptop for jaden children
like jaden who lives
in a bnb and is classed as homeless
you've got no problem accessing
microsoft teams
now back in school jayden says the
additional support is still needed
it's very important because say if we
didn't have them teachers
um then some of the students students
who've been lost kind of thing with no
help
and it's still helpful during school
time as well because
if you need someone to talk you can go
and talk to one of them or a different
teacher
and what sort of things does that help
with family problems
anything really you just need someone to
talk to there is a mechanism set up to
support disadvantaged children like
jaden in schools
the pupil premium is paid by the
government to schools as additional
funding for every pupil who's entitled
to free school meals
so for a primary school pupil they get
an additional
1 345 pounds and for a secondary pupil
it's 955 pounds traditionally
the government bases its calculation on
figures from january
but this year the pupil premium
calculation is based on the number of
children on free school meals
last october new research by campaign
group
f40 shows that in just that three-month
period
there's been an eight percent rise in
primary school children on free school
meals and a 3.5 percent rise
in secondary schools which is therefore
not factored
into budgets the research covers areas
in a third of england's educational
authorities finding
a budget shortfall of 36 million pounds
in lincolnshire alone it's 1.5 million
our numbers have increased by about 90
children so we've gone from just under
50 percent of our children qualifying
for free school meal and people premium
to nearly 60 percent
and significant proportion of those have
come onto the system since the october
census
so the way the funding works that we
lagged we won't get it any time soon but
we're still having to meet the needs of
those children
the department of education says the
calculation was moved to october to help
schools plan their budgets earlier in
the year
and that even on the october calculation
pupil premium funding is
expected to increase but those looking
out for children in poorer communities
say they will have a shortfall that
funds
people like myself as education welfare
officers
tas one-to-one support so yeah it is
going to be quite difficult for the next
next year or two at maple thought
primary near skegness
betty the therapy dog is a new
innovation kids having a hard time can
pet her or go for a walk
and she sometimes comes to visit if they
don't turn up at school
sometimes i get angry a lot so when i
get angry
i miss higginbotham sometimes takes me
out with betty and she always helps k
helps me calm down how do you calm
people down exactly
what no one's denying is that poverty in
young families
is on the rise bringing additional
problems for children
and schools say the funds should match
the needs
jason farrell sky news